and I worry that we are caring into the
matchup that nobody wants again fake
conservative Alysa Farah now she's
supposed to be the conservative who
would defend a conservative point of
view maybe defend a republican every now
and again she's always going after
disantis but here she is doing a little
PR she used to be in PR here she is
doing a little PR for the Democrats
thing I wanted to say on the vice
president's response and maybe this is
just my PR mind the first words out of
my mouth would have been Joe Biden's
going to serve four more years but I'm
ready that was the only thing that I
kind of took it as don't even
acknowledge from the democrat's
perspective that there is a chance she
might have to step in because it re kind
of gives fuel to this narrative that
allegedly 73% of Americans feel that
he's too old but bigger picture here 20
24 is giving me 2016 Vibes all over
again whether it's the massive
Republican field that's actually just
making the way for Donald Trump to be
the nominee but then also I get he's an
incumbent but the sort of Coronation of
Joe Biden reminds me of Hillary Clinton
primaries are meant to create the best
general election candidate I actually
think if he was kind of being challenged
in a primary he'd he'd come up with the
best way to answer about Hunter Biden
the Afghanistan withdrawal you've passed
all these bills but why do people not
feel like the economy is better um and I
worry that we are craning into the
matchup that nobody wants again Donald
Trump versus Joe Biden and that there's
a very legitimate chance that he could
lose okay I will give credit where
creditors du I think at the end she's
basically saying that Biden should have
a prime
right because he should have to defend
some of his ideas I think that's what
she sort of said there I was writing
down a whole bunch of things during that
uh but the idea that she made sense is
so bizarre whatever okay so that's one
part I'll give her credit for but this
other part we should just uh ignore we
should just ignore that 73% of Americans
feel he's too old uh no we should not
ignore that that it doesn't matter if
you're a Republican or a Democrat that
is a huge issue that he is and again
it's not purely about the age if you if
you were
hyper uh energetic and Hyper competent
at 81 years old then I suppose you could
be the the president of the United
States still but again does anyone think
this guy for one day could be assistant
manager at McDonald's and the answer
obviously is no the handlers the people
who tell them what to do the note cards
the rambling the confusion we'll show
you some stuff from Vietnam and and
India in just a moment uh it just it
never ends with this guy but I but on
the Alyssa Farah part and I don't like
making about these people specifically
but she's brought on this show called
The View which which again we've talked
about this a lot I think we've shown you
the beginning the original beginning of
the view that Barbara Walter set up from
20 plus years ago the whole purpose of
the view was to take women of different
life uh Lifestyles different backgrounds
ethnicities religions color of skin all
those things and together they could
discuss their viewpoints and thus would
be the view right that was the original
idea but what you get is you get five
sort of crazy far lefties and then one
fake conservative I would say she's
someone like Alissa you're basically
just controlled opposition you're there
to basically destroy Republicans and
conservatives and and take out your own
side and and do it nicely enough so you
get pet on the head and you get your
cookie and then one day they'll take you
out too so again I as I've said it's
like lady I hope you're enjoying what
does she get paid per year have we ever
Googled that it's a couple hundred grand
right I hope it's worth the 400 Grand
like that's a nice salary and I hope I
hope it's worth it to like sell out
everything that you purportedly believe
in
am